i've been asked to do some more limit
problems so let's do some more
so let's see what's the first problem i
have it says the limit
the limit
as x approaches zero
as x approaches 0
of x
minus 2 times the absolute value of x
over
the absolute value of x
now what immediately confuses most
people is this absolute value thing
because you know what how do you deal
with it because you can't just subtract
you know if this was an x it would be a
simple problem because then you could
just simplify it you could subtract this
2x from this x and then divide by x and
you'd get an answer this has an absolute
value so you can't just directly
manipulate it
but what if we were able to get rid of
this absolute value how do we do that
well
in order for this limit to exist in
order for this limit i don't know let's
say it equals l
right and l is what we have to solve for
in order for that limit to exist then
the limit to x approaches zero also has
to exist from the positive and the
negative sides what do i mean well that
means that this must also be true
the limit
as x approaches 0 from the right hand
side right from positive numbers
of
x minus 2 times the absolute value of x
over the absolute value of x has to be
equal to l and then it we also know that
the limit
as x approaches 0 from the negative side
of the same
function 2 times absolute value of x
over the absolute value of x is also
going to be equal to l right if if this
if we as we approach zero from the left
we get some number and as we approach
zero from the right we get the same
number then we know that no matter what
direction we approach a zero from which
is this situation we approach that
number so let's figure out these two
limits and if they have the same answer
then we have the answer to our original
problem
so how can we simplify this as x
approaches zero from the positive side
well
that's the same thing as the limit
as x approaches 0 from the positive side
well if we know we're approaching 0 from
the positive side what do we know about
x
we know that x is positive
right it's approaching from the right
so if x is positive we can get rid of
these absolute value signs so we just
get
x
minus 2 x
over x
and so that equals
the limit as x approaches 0 from the
positive side let's see that's x minus
2x
this is
minus x
right x minus minus x and then minus x
divided by
x
is minus one
so the limit as x approaches zero from
the other side of minus one well that's
just going to equal minus one
that just equals minus one
okay now let's take this case down here
when we're approaching from the negative
side when we're approaching from the
negative side
so
how can we think about this what is the
absolute value of x if x is a negative
number
well the absolute value of x if x is a
negative number is going to be
the negative of x right if x let's think
of it this way if x is negative 1 when
we take the absolute value of x we're
essentially just multiplying x times
negative 1 again
so another way to rewrite this is this
is equal to
this is equal to the limit
as x
approaches 0
from the negative side
of x
minus
2 times
what the absolute value of x is the same
thing as negative x
hopefully that makes sense to you right
if we're dealing with negative numbers
then taking the absolute value of a
negative number is the same thing as
multiplying that negative number times a
negative to essentially make it into a
positive number
right
and then of course the absolute value of
x in the denominator since we're dealing
with a negative number is also equal to
negative x
and let's see if we can simplify that so
that means that the limit
as x
approaches
0 from the negative side
let's see i get x
minus 2 times negative x so these
negatives cancel out so i get x plus 2x
right
x plus 2x i get 3x
over minus x
so 3x so this is 3x
so 3x over minus x that equals
minus three
so this is interesting
i am approaching a different number when
i approach it from the left hand side
when i approach this function from the
left hand side or from the right-hand
side so
it looks like this limit doesn't exist
and let's let's confirm that let me let
me actually
let me see if i can
let me
let me get the graphing calculator and
confirm
let me type it in
so x
minus
i'll show you what i'm doing
x so you don't get bored x minus
absolute value of
x and what am i
what am i draw divided by the absolute
value of x
divided by
absolute value of x
let's see graph
and what does it have here zoom out
zoom out
so this is is this right
x minus the absolute value of x
oh sorry it's x minus 2 times the
absolute value of x
times the absolute value of x
graph
there you go
even the oh i don't think you can see it
yet the graphing calculator confirms the
work we did
although it connects them and it makes
you think that it somehow approaches
here but that's just because it picks
points and just plots them
so as you see as you approach from the
right hand side you approach negative 1
right
and as well and you're at negative 1 the
whole time in the right hand side as you
approach from the left-hand side you
approach negative 3. so the limit does
not exist at x is equal 0. you would say
l is undefined
and you know there's a little dirty
secret about limits and and it's not a
dirty secret but in theory you should
never get a limit problem wrong and why
well you you should be able to solve it
analytically but if you don't know how
to solve an anal just put in really
really small numbers here try out you
know if you put in point try point zero
zero zero one like right try try numbers
that are just slightly larger than what
whatever your limit number is and then
slightly smaller and then just
numerically if you have a calculator see
what it's approaching sometimes you
don't even need a calculator you know
you could probably calculate this in
your head with 0.01 or something like
that
anyway let's do another problem
invert colors
okay so let's do
the limit
as
x
approaches zero
of sine of five x
over
two x
now this looks a lot like sine of x over
x and we know sine of x over x what is
that
and if you don't believe me watch the
videos where we prove it using the
squeeze theorem
we prove that the limit as x approaches
0 of sine of x
over x is equal to 1. now this looks
almost like that it'd be great if we
could get it into that form and then
we'd be done so how can we do that
well let's try to substitute let's try
to get a single variable here instead of
a five times a variable so let's
make a substitution
in magenta
and say that a
is equal to five x
and then that also means that
so divide both sides by five and we get
x
is equal to a over five so let's make
that substitution into this so
this if if
the limit as x approaches 0 would be the
same thing as what
if x approaches as x approaches 0 here a
is also going to approach 0 right so
this is the same thing as the limit as a
approaches zero
or you could view it this way as a
approaches zero x is still approaching
zero maybe at one fifth the base but
it's the same thing
so sorry edit
undo
edit undo
edit undo edit oh not enough
okay anyway this this should say the
limit is a
approaches zero
right and hopefully you're satisfied
that the limit as a approaches zero is
the same that x is still approaching
zero right because if a approaches zero
here that's going to make x approach
zero so it's the limit as a approaches
zero of sine of a
sine of a
over two times x but x is a over five so
it's 2 times a over 5.
and so that is equal to
the limit
as
a
approaches 0
of sine
of a
over
two-fifths
a
well that's the same thing we could take
this this out we could take this one
over two-fifths right it's in the
denominator out this is just a constant
term so we could take it out of the
limit and obviously if we're taking out
of the denominator it flips right
because this is just this is one over
two fifths or five halves
so that equals
five halves right i just took this out
of the denominator and it flips right
because it's one over two fifths times
the limit
as a approaches zero of sine
of a
over a
and now that looks an awful lot like
this it's just we have an a instead of
an x but that doesn't make a difference
so this is equal to one so this whole
thing since this is equal to one
is equal to
five halves
and once again if you get this answer
and you're not so sure take your
calculator out and try you know
calculate what is the sign of
5 times 0.001 so sine of 0.005
divided by
2 times 0.001 so 0.002
if you take that you're going to get a
number that's awfully close to this
number you know this is approximate this
is 2 this is exactly 2.5 you're probably
going to get like
2.49999 or something like that
so let's do another one
let's do another one
okay
so i have
the limit
as x
approaches 0. this one looks a lot like
the previous one although we have some
exponents here
of sine
squared of x
over x squared
and that almost looks like sine of x
over x but i have these squared terms
what can i do
well this is the same this is sine of x
squared over x squared so this is this
is the same thing as
the limit
as x approaches 0 of
sine
of x over x
squared right if you were to take this
out you'd square the numerator square
the denominator and you get this if you
took if you wanted to
change this i won't say simplify it
well now this is interesting
well this 2
is this is a constant term this isn't
going to change with the limit so
essentially we could say well this is
going to be equal to
the limit
as x approaches 0 of sine
of x over x the whole thing squared and
how is that i couldn't have done this if
there was like an x here right because
that that would have changed the limit
but this is a constant term
so
this the the base not the base is the
only thing that's going to change as i
take as x approaches zero so i can take
the limit within i within the base i
guess you could say i didn't get here
and now we're back to what we proved in
a previous video what is the limit as x
approaches zero of sine of x over x
right it's it's one
so what's one squared
it is one
there you go
and i've taken 13 minutes of your time
hopefully you found it vaguely useful